what's going on reject nation we are
going to watch the trailer for the fifth
purge movie
the forever purge man our venom reaction
wasn't monetized and our green knight
trailer reaction was partially blocked
and universal never lets you monetize
well that's okay greg cause today's
video is sponsored by manscaped
what we get to purge the hair off of our
balls
and recoup some losses from monetization
shenanigans that's right greg manscaped
makes some of the finest men's grooming
products in all the land
especially when it comes to trimming you
nowhere
crotch and manscaped is making trimming
and grooming easier and safer than ever
with their new and improved
lawnmower 4.0 i used a lawnmower
on someone during the perch it was great
that's not the same kind of lawnmower
greg the lawnmower 4 is
waterproof and wireless which makes it
quite easy and convenient to shave in
the shower
it has their patented skin safe
technology with ceramic blades to help
keep you from nicking your
good bits now they got four different
lengths to choose from you just slide
this guy on here
one notch you get the longest another
notch you get a little shorter
pop this next guy on if you really want
to crop it close it's also got a new
wireless charging
system helping with that waterproof game
just plop it in here
then you plug that guy into the wall you
get up to 90
minutes of shave time on a fully charged
battery so take a long shower and the
coolest thing is they got this new
multi-function
on off switch and if you click it three
times rapidly
you will engage the travel safe mode
which means you're not going to
accidentally turn it on inside of a
suitcase or something which i've done
in real life a lot click it three more
times and you're back
into shave mode buddy look at that can
you kill someone with it
i don't think you should make jokes like
that in a sponsored segment
yeah but i was trying to tie it into the
purse so use our promo code reel20 to
save yourself
20 on a new lawnmower for the perfect
package really
any of the fantastic products at
manscape.com
and remember you know clean your balls
up
so it's not a real lawn mower
i thought that was a trailer for a
trailer no it's not
[Music]
what happens the rest of the year
[Applause]
whoa
what the hell
is that josh lucas i don't think so
[Music]
i feel like i'm watching an army of the
dead trees
[Music]
maybe it is joshua
is josh lucas
[Music]
this wow like an apocalypse movie yeah
[Applause]
you damn purge movies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
damn purge movies keep hooking me
packaged i know
just where i think i'm out you
pull me back in the only one i haven't
seen is the first perch and i barely
remember
election year i was on some stuff that
night
i really liked purge but i could have
sworn he ended the purge
following the presidential elections
from the last year and the abolition of
the purge a mexican couple escaping from
a drug cartel is stranded on a texas
ranch there they will be at the mercy of
a group of outsiders who plan to
unlawfully continue their own purge and
turn against them
to eliminate that it was a little
confusing in the trailer it seemed like
it was just like continuing the day
after the purge and then they're just
gonna keep the purge going
yeah yeah so that's where i was a little
bit lost i was like wait a minute are
they continuing these election results
lost or not well and they do that thing
that every purge trailer has happened
[ __ ] what they're doing is absolutely
political
absolutely i think it gets a little
confusing because the trailer does what
every purge trailer has to do which is
where you know whoever's the character
this time is like oh man one night a
year miss crazy but the rest of the year
is fine they
always seem to want to be very relevant
and cutting in terms of their commentary
and i feel like certain purge movies get
closer than others to doing that but i
always appreciate their gusto in going
for that and yeah watching this i was
like
we're going right out of the headlines
oh yeah i know with the
not accepting the election results yeah
and hunting down a couple of outsiders
you know
seeking refuge lee people who are trying
to get to mexico
right now yeah you know it's it's
relevant they always have the
thrills and the you know
post-apocalyptic looking
mayhem i hope that they can you know
dial up
at least whatever conversation they're
trying to bring into this to the point
that it feels like a substantial part of
the movie as well
it looks shot so different it really the
whole time i was watching i'm like this
looks like the army of the dead trailer
the lead is in the army of the dead
actually that woman oh really
yeah it's a different director for the
purge i can't remember when uh
james demara de monaco demarco left
he wrote this movie but yeah okay so i
mean he directed a bunch of them and now
he's sort of handed off the reigns and
yeah it definitely does have a different
visual
punch to it i mean i love it i love the
way they're dealing with their focus and
their focal lengths throughout this
whole trailer
and like similar to how the army of the
dead trailer there's so many of the
shots of just the obscure blurred
backgrounds
there's a lot of that here yeah what's
scary about it is it's taking place
during the day
you know whereas the other purge movies
you associate that with a really gritty
nighttime look and this
feels like it's scary just to be out and
about during the day there's something
really unsettling about it the world is
crumbling there is this sort of
apocalyptic
very metal type of vibe i really love
this trailer i've gotta make
it yeah this really the first franchise
is always that thing where i'm like oh
you know sometimes i quite enjoy it and
other times like man you really missed
the mark and this is
the trailer where i'm like oh god you
got me you got me hooked back in now
you got me hooked back in and it seemed
like it was destined to go down this
path
yeah you know and i love how they are
dealing with the inhabiting the world of
they don't accept the election results
it's more than just a commentary on what
happened with the most recent election
it's
something that would occur within the
world of the purge it's the boiling over
of these convictions yeah
people would need this release they
would need it and then you eliminate
that you take away
something that they feel that they've
had a freedom to exercise and now they
can't do it you would get
something like this so i love kind of
the the direction they're going with
what's happening to this world when you
don't have the purge how people would
take this in their own hands and now
it's just like oh
now you eliminate that now crime's gonna
be happening worse than ever
yeah yeah now there's gonna be a scary
group of new founding fathers you know
sympathizers or whatever and two i mean
this continues their oscillating door of
just like
what new setting can we put the purge in
now and i like that yeah we're in
a more rural area and you know in areas
that look like they're somewhat deserted
and out in the boonies and you know in
that border area between texas and
mexico perhaps like yeah
i like that setting and the vibe that it
brings in the sort of different tone
that that enables
the fifth purge to have it gets a little
bit of like army of the dead meets that
what the hell is that movie killing not
killing season uh
the movie would that people were mad
about about from blumhouse
with the girl from the wrestling show
betty gilpin
oh um uh the hunt the hunt yeah yeah oh
my god they got their simplest titles
like it's kind of a mishmash of
those vibes with of course the purge
mixed in but yeah i i was uh i'm
pleasantly surprised by how much i
enjoyed this trailer
like some badass stunts some great
effects and stuff i mean goat trapped
seemed kind of stupid to me i was like
that seems like it looks like an obvious
ass trapper
like almost a rural saw trap it's so
elaborate too
yeah yeah all right guys well the
forever purge
did you like this trailer did you hate
this trailer does this obvious ass
political commentary upset you
i can see why it's always had a
political undertone but it's
this is like the most overt one i think
that's ever been presented in this
franchise subscribe to the real rejects
click the notification bell thank you to
manscape for sponsoring this video last
but not least
pandemic jones if you want
someone in your 2021 purge
to be fighting with you yeah you're
gonna want to get
pandemic jones you're gonna want the guy
who declares himself to be the one who
can jones his way through
the pandemic knocking people out left
and right we
see your profile pic yeah do you look
like i'm really doing a john shout out
here you really look like
joint you really look like the kind of
guy who
seems nice and approachable but that's
the best thing about you you can
bait people in and then bam stab them in
the jugular
right trap them in some type of crazy
contraption because apparently this
movie is now part of the soft franchise
of course
pandemic jones you have supported us for
so long and now you will lead us
into surviving the forever of the purge
because you are the pj please don't
purge me i'll get to the olivia rodrigo
video